just think back to the enormous
Powerball fervor that gripped the entire
country that's okay for me to develop a
lineup and enjoy the aspect of becoming
a general manager for a team for a day
that's not okay
Brian Greenwood is a professor husband
and father he also represents the
typical fantasy sports player unlike
traditional fantasy leagues that span
over the course of an entire season
daily fantasy contests last a single day
in 2015 over 56 million Americans
played fantasy sports since the first
sight showed up online nearly 10 years
ago daily fantasy has grown to a
multi-billion dollar business with
draftkings and FanDuel leading the
industry I'm a casual or micro stakes
players what they say so I own a daily
basis is anywhere from five to ten
dollars a day is what out would I'll
spend in entry fees I really like the
excitement of trying to get that line up
perfect where you get that big payday
now I haven't had that big payday yet
while Greenwood waits for his big payday
many states are examining the legality
of one-day fantasy sports leagues that
have exploded in popularity over the
last few years just tuned your
television to any sports channel and
you're likely to see ads for a daily
fantasy sports contest it's like a new
season every time you play and best of
all you could win a shipload of money
while sports betting is mostly illegal
in the u.s. fantasy sports has a special
exemption thanks to the unlawful
internet gambling Enforcement Act passed
by Congress in 2006 but even with the
federal carve out the legal status of
daily fantasy remains murky because each
state gets to define what constitutes
gambling mark Edelman a law professor at
Baruch College and writer for Forbes
magazine has covered the daily fantasy
industry since its infancy under state
law a contest and tete is considered to
be illegal gambling if three elements
are met consideration which is an entry
fee prize and chance while that standard
is the same in all 50 states what
differs state-by-state
the definition of chance despite
questions of its legality fantasy sports
sites operated mostly under the radar
until an incident in the fall of 2015
brought scrutiny to the industry out of
the scandal swirling around those
fantasy sports sites New York's Attorney
General now investigating FanDuel and
draftkings to find out if some of their
employees one large amounts of money
thanks to inside information the story
that's told pretty much by the media is
that a draftkings employee had won a
high-stakes contest on FanDuel with
purported access to insider information
about who people were predicting while
Edelman supports some measure of
regulation to prevent fraud he sees
other factors contributing to daily
fantasy investigations but there are two
other pieces to the puzzle that led to
much greater attention for daily fantasy
sports in New York the daily fantasy
sports companies until just about a year
ago spent very little money on
television advertising they were not
seen as big business and not getting
much attention well in week 1 of the NFL
season this year both draftkings and
FanDuel finished on the top 10 list for
most money spent on television
advertising so activities that were
operating almost under the radar perhaps
seeing me too small for government
attention now was seen as big business
at the same time daily fantasy ads
returning heads New Jersey had their
effort to legalize sports betting
quashed by the u.s. Third Circuit Court
of Appeals
perhaps frustrated by the fact sports
leagues were making money off daily
fantasy and not supporting sports
gambling in his state representative
Frank pallone penned a letter to his
colleagues in Congress warning of the
dangers of daily fantasy this is this is
unregulated it's the Wild West you don't
really know based on what we found out
last week that you're making a fair bet
pallone found hypocritical the fact that
Major League Baseball and the NBA were
directly profiting from daily fantasy
sports but wanted to keep out sports
gambling and rather than write the
letter in the tone that talked about the
virtues of allowing sports gambling in
New Jersey pallone coined this letter
warning of the risks of daily fantasy
sports and suggesting it needs to be
investigated with growing government
attention to daily fantasy activities
and
now news of a possible scandal new
york's ambitious Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman decided to go after
operations in his state arguing they
were illegal games of chance daily
fantasy sports which we've been looking
into for over a month we've concluded is
not some new version of fantasy sports
it's really just a new version of online
gambling in his cease and desist notices
sent to draftkings and FanDuel
Schneiderman claimed the company's
engaged in illegal activity as they
promote daily fantasy sports like a
lottery representing the game to New
Yorkers as a path to easy riches that
anyone can win and here's where things
get confusing because in New York it's
legal to play the lottery in fact their
sales pitch is surprisingly similar to
that of daily fantasy sites introducing
sweet million from the New York Lottery
your best chance to win a million for a
dollar and it's not just the lottery
New Yorkers can also bet on horse racing
or visit any of the six licensed Indian
casinos in the state and these state run
gambling institutions are often prone to
this same corruption that occurs in
private sector operations so why are
those forms of gaming ok and not daily
fantasy sports
UNLV director of Gaming research David
Schwartz explains I think to an extent
recent state actions are about
protecting innocent victims and ensuring
clear protection but another big piece
of that has to be then protecting their
monopoly to regulate and offer gambling
services within their state the debate
around fantasy sports isn't so much an
argument over the definitions of skill
versus chance but evidence that
America's pseudo ban on sports gambling
is inherently hypocritical and
ineffective since the early days there's
been two different competing feelings in
America one is that people like to
gamble so let them do it
the other one is well everybody except
for me can't really handle gambling so
to me this is just the latest wrinkle as
long as technology advances and this is
going way back to the first dice you
know as long as technology is advancing
people are going to use it to gamble the
fantasy sports industry isn't going down
without a fight
and is quickly mobilizing in response to
Schneiderman's crusade Steve Miller who
played part in the effort to legalize
online poker has organized the daily
fantasy sports Players Alliance to
represent players across the country
no one wants to play a game where the
rules of the game change state-by-state
players want to play a game and we just
want the protection we know that we're
playing in a even playing field even
Dallas Mavericks owner and business
mogul Mark Cuban has thrown in his
support speaking before the fantasy
sports trade association this January
when the [ __ ] hits the fan right it
tends to blow all the [ __ ] everywhere
but then it's clean so while today
really seems bad and while it seems like
you're under attack that's the good news
because when they're attacking you
everything has to be cleaned up the
proverbial crap may be hitting the fan
for fantasy sports but will it provide
an opportunity to an act scene or gaming
laws I really wish we were like the rest
of the world where sports gambling was
legal and we could get it out of the
shadows my thing is when things are in
the shadows the potential for abuse is
far greater I think what it's really
important to remember at the end of the
day is that people have been gambling
for a really long time probably for more
than 10,000 years there's been balls
against it there's in laws legalizing it
the nice thing to do might be to have a
rational conversation about to what
extent does our society want adults who
don't have problems gambling to be
allowed to gamble prohibition doesn't
work it didn't work in poker it didn't
work with alcohol it doesn't work with a
host of other ranges of Industry
prohibition with DFS is not the answer